from navy seal to cia operative
to a member of the top secret third
echelon splinter cell program
and eventually the commander of the
fourth echelon sam fisher's career has
spanned decades
and has been located across the globe
though he has attempted to retire a
number of times
his spec ops life has essentially become
a part of his dna
he has well and truly become what he
does
having already taken part of the ghost
recon universe in both wildlands and
breakpoint
it has now been announced that he'll be
joining team rainbow
though there seems to be something else
that is motivating this move
highly secretive and vastly experienced
who is sam fisher
and what is he planning
what happens next is up to you
born in 1957 in towson maryland
sam's father was a 25-year veteran case
officer
for the central intelligence agency who
worked undercover in moscow during the
cold war
little is known about his childhood but
after his parents died
he attended a military boarding school
later he was accepted into the united
states naval academy where he graduated
in 1980
with a bachelor's degree in political
science and was commissioned as an
officer in the u.s navy
not long after his file was flagged for
recruitment by the navy seals
of which he joined after passing the
grueling selection process and training
program
during the mid-80s sam worked for the
cia under the cover of being deployed as
a diplomatic aide
in eastern europe during this time he
met an nsa
crypt analyst named regan burns in the
then soviet
socialist republic of georgia
after a short time together regan felt
pregnant and following a small wedding
ceremony they had a baby girl
named sarah born on the 31st of may
1985.
although they loved each other they had
a difficult marriage their professions
kept them at a distance
and eventually after three years of
marriage they divorced
regan went back to the united states and
took cyril with her reclaiming her
maiden name
and changing cirrus sam created distance
between himself and them
he placed focus on his job while he was
operating in afghanistan
east germany and the soviet satellite
states
in the years leading up to the collapse
of the ussr
later on regan got sick and eventually
died of ovarian cancer
cyril was 15. after gaining guardianship
of sarah
sam moved back to the us and took a desk
job with the cia
where he worked on weapons development
as well as studying experimental
weaponry and information warfare
this enabled him to spend more quality
time with his daughter as a result they
became closer
and he was able to finally fulfill his
role of her father and make a positive
contribution to her upbringing
during his time as a navy seal sam
participated in a number of special
operations in bolivia
senegal colombia kosovo and the persian
gulf
he also led a number of operations
around the world in various conflict
zones
amid his naval career sam also spent
nearly three years
working as an intelligence analyst and
over time he was awarded the defence
distinguished service medal and around
1996 was honorably discharged from the
navy
a recently retired sam fisher underwent
training at the farm
in camp perry virginia
this training was to demonstrate to the
director of the third echelon
colonel lambert that he had the
appropriate skills to successfully
perform in the field
as a member of the newly created
splinter cell program for the nsa's
third echelon initiative
over a period of time communications
have become more sophisticated
and digital encryption more expensive
passive collection had simply been
rendered inefficient
so the third echelon a top secret
organization was tasked with leading the
american information warfare initiative
the primary goal of the organization was
to serve as the equivalent of the
special forces
in the modern age of technology and
information warfare
by physically obtaining intelligence and
locations where all other means
had been exhausted its most significant
initiative
was a splinter cell program in which
lone operatives
called splinter cells did field work in
sensitive areas around the world
like a slither of glass these units
operated seamlessly
undetected by electronic and human
enemies alike
and were able to infiltrate highly
sensitive locations and collect
intelligence by any means necessary
unlike the cia's field operatives their
identities were kept secret
even from other government agencies
the testing requirements for this
division included interrogation
bypassing surveillance systems lock
picking obstacle navigation
stealth and extremely lethal and
non-lethal force
surprised by his skill the director
personally welcomed sam into the nsa
third echelon over the years
he participated in a number of
operations including the rescue of a cia
agent
the capture of a former cia militia
leader in the investigation of a mole
working within the nsa
in late 2007 while on a deep undercover
mission in iceland
he was pulled out and lambert broke the
news to him that his daughter
sarah was allegedly killed by a drunk
driver
unable to cope the loss of his daughter
sam is relieved from his duty as a
splinter cell
eventually after some times passed
lambert reassigned him to a high-risk
deep cover operation to infiltrate the
ranks of john brown's army
a domestic terrorist organization
he went undercover as a convicted felon
and prison inmate
and after proving himself was introduced
to the organization and offered
membership
he accepted becoming a double agent
within the jba
in 2011 three years after the death of
his daughter
and no longer active within the third
echelon he heard a rumor that sarah's
death was no accident
and went to malta to investigate
after being captured by the third
echelon in malta it was revealed that
cyril was alive
but if he wanted to see his daughter
again he had to help investigate
a mole that was working from the inside
of the organization
at third echelon hq a recording was
played to him which explained that
sarah's death was faked
to prevent her from being used as
leverage by the mole to compromise sam
and the agency after hearing this
sam agreed to help stop the mall and
assist him preventing the assassination
of the president of the united states
eventually he was reunited with his
daughter and once again
retired from government work
however unsurprisingly bored with
civilian life sam accepted a job from an
old associate
and good friend victor cost at paladin 9
security
which specialised in high-tech defence
solutions and hostage recovery but when
cost was injured during an attack at
anderson air base in guam
not long after sam is off the position
of commander of the fourth echelon
by the president
at some point during 2019 sam is
deployed in bolivia
in order to recover sensitive
intelligence data from a rogue cia
officer
knowing full well the mission is going
to be incredibly difficult he contacts
cia case officer
karen berman in order to borrow a ghost
recon fire team
sam's deployment takes him to a uni-dead
base in la cruz
where he infiltrates the base ahead of
the ghosts and assassinates the rogue
agent prior to their arrival
upon greeting nomad sam hacks into the
uni-dead servers
in order to erase all traces of the
sensitive information while nomad's team
provides tactical support and security
while leaving the base sam discloses the
nature of the intelligence to nomad
revealing it to contain sensitive high
technology research and development
that could change the nature of warfare
and put the special operations community
out of business
in 2025 sam is assigned by the us
government
to hunt down a high-value target called
the strategist
who had been kidnapping military
specialists all over the globe
the fact that aurora can't be entered
sam calls in the help of victor cost
in aurora he meets up with nomad and
they team up to rescue nomad's teammate
midas and also take down project claw a
new form of drone swarm technology
that has been made by skeltek forcefully
by sentinel ceo
trey stone they successfully managed to
capture the strategist
and sam assures nomad before leaving
with the hvt
that he will present the hvt to the
right people so they can deploy the
military cavalry
into a rower sam and cost
leave the island and the paladin before
the drone control program gets
reactivated
sam fisher would later be recruited by
team rainbow to be the first member
of rainbow operational staff the
evaluation carried out on sam
highlights how very little information
is available in regards to his past
missions
as the nature of his position has always
had him operate on a need to know basis
essentially his role involved managing
incredibly sensitive situations
and effectively cleaning up any loose
ends while remaining undetected
[Applause]
he has a strong sense of moral justice
and he believes in never leaving a man
behind
specialist thinker remembers
encountering him as a child
as he was an acquaintance of her father
she recalls the impression that he left
on her
a person who truly sees others for who
they are and not what you might expect
them to be
he also proved to have an excellent
measure of how to approach an individual
in order to either work with them or
overthrow them
despite his age along with the length of
time he has technically been off duty
sam is kept in good shape however
there does seem to be an ulterior motive
to him joining the team
something he is unwilling to share
though this should come as no surprise
after all sam has always been
tight-lipped as the nature of his
previous assignments
has never required him to disclose
information to outsiders
[Applause]
but regardless of the singularity the
team are willing to take full advantage
of his vast experience while he's here
sam fisher has been involved in numerous
armed conflicts around the globe
for nearly two decades and a lot of them
have been highly unorthodox
his extensive service career boasts a
number of geological hotspots
including iran the persian gulf colombia
and afghanistan
during the course of his career he also
undertook various covert assignments
including russia panama north and south
korea
and the former soviet republic of
georgia
it's clear that the constant training
regular combat and undercover operations
have defined as adult life
and not only has he survived but he has
thrived in this type of environment
his insatiable curiosity tactical
experience and brisk honesty
has made him a seemingly unstoppable
force and he has well and truly become
identifiable by his accomplishments
however in order to achieve this title
he has had to make a number of personal
sacrifices
and bury deep certain aspects of his
personality
over time he's adapted to this role and
more importantly learned to sharpen his
ability to detach himself
emotionally from a situation to get the
job done
his perspective and observant nature
paired with his often distinctly dark
sense of humor
enables him to master his fears and keep
him focused while in the field
honest and abrasive he's very little
time for dishonesty
and prefers to cut through the general
social dribble and get on with the job
at hand
over time he has obtained a number of
combat experiences many scars
and a place in military history and
while there is little left to be proved
to the world
he has no interest in glory if he fights
it's because he believes he is capable
of provoking positive change
sam fisher and splinter cell spans
decades in the gaming industry
and this has really only been a small
summary of what's happened in sam's
career
but with the recent addition to other
tom clancy titles like wildlands
breakpoint and soon rainbow six siege
one could be forgiven for assuming that
we may soon be seeing
a little more of him in an upcoming
release
[Music]
i hope you found this interesting i'm
very much looking forward to talking
more about sam fisher
if what i think is going to happen comes
to fruition
anyway thank you very much for watching
and i'll catch you in the next one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
you